[Musique]
bonjour à vis de vous retrouver pour ce
premier set 8 échos de l'année le
magazine économique de notre territoire
sans plus tarder voici le sommaire
nous reviendrons sur les événements qui
ont marqué saint-quentin-en-yvelines de
janvier à avril 2017 avec un focus
notamment sur l'arrivée du ski cuba
guyancourt son directeur jean luc miraux
sera avec nous en plateau en 2017
l'agglomération a mis en avant les
atouts de son territoire à travers de
nombreux événements objectif séduire les
entreprises christine turc et de
beauregard responsable du pôle
attractivité immobilier d'entreprise à
saint-quentin-en-yvelines nous en dira
plus les événements économiques seront
encore nombreux cette année à saint
quentin en yvelines à quels sont
justement ces grands rendez vous en 2018
réponse dans ce numéro avec anne failli
directrice générale adjointe au
développement économique
les quatre premiers mois de l'année 2017
on était riche en rendez vous
économiques à saint quentin en yvelines
sans plus tarder voici une première
rétrospective et on en parle ensuite
avec notre invité
inaugurées fin décembre 2016 c'est en
janvier 2010 est qu'une dizaine de start
up ont pu intégrer le ski tube un
nouveau lieu dédié à l'entrepreneuriat
et à l'innovation située à guyancourt
ce qui compte c'est avant tout
un accélérateur de croissance un
accélérateur de contact des changes en
même temps très rapidement cette baisse
de concentration de savoir faire on leur
donne en avait dans les six mois c'est
quasiment l'exclure d'une grande école
de commerce
fin février saint quentin en yvelines
organise sa 21e semaine de l'emploi et
de la formation
le principe permettre aux saint
quentinois de s'informer et de découvrir
les métiers qui recrutent
une quinzaine d'événements a permis aux
personnes en recherche d'emploi de
rencontrer des entreprises
le 22 mars plus de 450 entrepreneurs
s'étaient donné rendez vous au ciel de
huy construction pour la deuxième grande
soirée des entrepreneurs de saint
quentin en yvelines
au programme tables rondes sur
l'innovation et remise des prix des
projets innovants lauréat dans la
catégorie pme et innove pour son projet
et iwate une autre connecter les tim
walsh est un projet très intéressant
actuelle notamment pour sécuriser les
malades d'alzheimer
donc c'est un projet innovant avec ce
qu'on appelle de l'internet par l'objet
d'objets connectés
alors vous l'avez vue là le début de
cette année 2010 est a été marquée par
l'arrivée des premiers et les arts et
des premiers incubés au ski cuba
jean-luc numéro bonjour à qu'on soit
vous êtes le directeur du ski cube à
guyancourt alors depuis un an combien de
startups ont pu bénéficier de ce
dispositif alors sur l'année 2010 est
une douzaine qui ont été sélectionnés
par un comité dédié qui est présidé par
le président de la communauté
d'agglomération de saint quentin et donc
nous avons retenu une douzaine de start
up sur une trentaine de candidatures
c'est un accompagnement qui dure entre 6
et 24 mois la science a donc c'est un
contrat que nous avons avec ces jeunes
dirigeants d'entreprise qui courent sur
une période qui peut aller de 6 à 25 à
24 mois alors qu'il ya déjà des start up
qui volent de leurs propres ailes
justement grâce au stick hub alors pas
encore mais nous sommes dans une période
où d'effectivement cette échéance se
rapproche pour beaucoup d'entrés elles
aujourd'hui certains d'entre elles
peuvent espérer développer du chiffre
d'affaires à très court terme jeu
pendant le trimestre qui vient et pour
d'autres nous sommes dans une logique un
peu différente une logique plutôt
d'expérimentation qui devrait leur
permettre avant d'entrer leurs produits
sur le marché de le tester en tous les
cas sur le territoire de saint quentin
c'est ce que nous faisons et nous
mettrons tout en oeuvre pour que ça
puisse se faire dans les meilleures
conditions
nouvelle promo alors évidemment
l'objectif c'est d'abord d'être très
sélectif pour être dans une logique
plutôt qualitative
donc nous aurons nous avons de toute
façon des arrivées des départs de
manière semestriels et pour l'année qui
nous espérons avoir entre 8,10 nouveau
nouveau à cuba mais tout ça fera l'objet
d'une sélection ce que je peux vous dire
dès à présent c'est que d'ici la semaine
afin de courant de la semaine prochaine
nous accueillerons trois nouvelles
start-up qui vont venir compléter
l'ensemble des entreprises que nous
accompagnons que vous allez proposer de
nouveaux services peut-être justement
pour c'est pour ces startups alors
évidemment nous continuons à développer
des outils nouveaux tout ça en tirant
aussi l'expérience de cette première
année d'activité et en s'appuyant sur
les souhaits des entreprises que nous
accompagnons donc le financement fait
l'objet d'une réflexion toute
particulière nous avons à ce jour des
dispositifs qui permettent aux
entreprises d'amorcer une activité mais
nous devons peut-être aller au delà et
c'est en tout cas une réflexion que nous
portons le business également être un
sujet important le ska business day est
une opération que nous menons depuis
deux ans maintenant et qui non seulement
doit perdurer mais peut-être se
développer voilà donc nous avons
beaucoup de pistes de réflexion puisque
le territoire est très riche
les entreprises sont particulièrement
demandés dans l'allée pour plus
d'informations un site internet en le
www.skype.com absolument merci jean luc
nero alors je vous propose maintenant de
continuer bien à remonter le temps et de
revenir sur les faits marquants de mai à
septembre 2010 est le 1er juin movéo le
pôle de compétitivité en recherche et
développement automobile et mobile
ite avait choisi l'estaca à saint
quentin en yvelines pour sa convention
annuelle
l'événement a réuni tous les acteurs
majeurs de ce secteur
au programme expositions ateliers et
conférences autour de ce thème mobilité
urbaine de la contrainte à l'adhésion du
29 juin au 2 juillet le golf national de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines accueillez la
101e édition de l'open de france
cette année la compétition a pris une
nouvelle dimension avec l'arrivée du
groupe d'investisseurs chinois à chennai
pendant quatre jours les meilleurs
golfeurs mondiaux se sont affrontés
devant 50000 spectateurs
nous sommes ravis de cette montée en
puissance de notre open national
et puis on croise les doigts pour ça se
poursuit dans l'autre tous les temps du
terme un mois de juillet marquée
également par un anniversaire lu vs qu a
soufflé ses 25 bougies
l'université versailles saint quentin
qui se place en 2017 au 40e rang mondial
dans le prestigieux classement de
shanghai une distinction en sciences de
la terre qui atteste notamment du niveau
d'excellence des équipes de recherche
enfin pour la rentrée 2010 est saint
quentin en yvelines a organisé le 7
septembre son premier salon en lien avec
le tourisme d'affaires le skymiles des
en parlant en échangeant sur différentes
sur différents rendez vous on s'est
rendu compte que d'une part il y avait
une véritable offre que les partenaires
ne se connaissaient pas forcément donc
c'était bien de les réunir une première
édition qui a rassemblé une soixantaine
d'entreprises travaillant dans
l'événementiel christine cirque et de
beauregard bonjour vous êtes responsable
du pôle attractivité immobilier
d'entreprise à saint quentin en yvelines
alors on vient de voir un sujet sur sur
le mas des justement en quoi cet
important pour saint quentin en yvelines
de mise et justement sur tourisme
d'affaires le territoire de 50 ans donc
de toutes façons veut agir auprès des
entreprises du territoire et les mettre
en les mettre en rapport
c'est vrai que là le maïs des était le
premier salon événementiel réalisé à
saint quentin en plein air ce qui est
plutôt une première
en général les salons du tourisme
d'affaires se déroule plutôt sur paris
et l'a donc nous avons voulu créer cet
événement un événement plutôt ludique
avec quatre espaces différents au sein
de ce salon et dans lesquels justement
les entreprises présentes on a eu plus
de 360 entreprises des tpe pme des
grands groupes qui sont venus découvrir
justement l'offre que pouvait proposer
les entreprises saint-quentinoise des
offres à la fois sur le des séminaires
des événements d'entreprise et pouvoir
tester en direct sur place puisque
c'était un salon qui se voulait ludique
les entreprises pouvaient tester à la
fois les traiteurs des des vols de
drones des il y avait des magiciens
enfin voilà donc un salon très très
différent de ce qui peut se passer
normalement alors juste un mois sur
cette étude sur le tourisme d'affaires
qui avait été lancée justement peu après
le maïs des pour un petit peu mieux
connaître la clientèle où on est cette
étude alors cette étude nous attendons
justement pour le 7 février
les résultats déjà du diagnostic
puisqu'il faut d'abord savoir ce que
l'on a sur le territoire avant de
pouvoir proposer une stratégie est de
pouvoir surtout essayer de définir une
filière sur le tourisme d'affaires car
c'est quand même une filière importante
et donc donc là pour le moment nous en
sommes à la phase du diagnostic
le 7 février nous organisons un
événement justement hausse qui cumule
donc on rebondit un événement au ski
cube pour présenter à la fois ce
diagnostic est présentée également le
dispositif de la razer de la ryder cup
on en parlera d'ailleurs dans quelques
minutes avec anne cyrus pense que c'est
un des grands rendez vous voilà le 2018
alors christine turc et de beauregard
vous êtes également responsable du pôle
immobilier d'entreprise
saint-quentin-en-yvelines justement
étaient présents 1 sur plusieurs
événements cette année on va regarder
justement cette dernière rétrospective
on en parle juste après 600 entreprises
700 participants et 4000 rendez vous
d'affaires c'est le bilan de la deuxième
édition du skype
et ce dès le 5 octobre dernier tpe pme
et grands groupes ont pu se rencontrer
l'occasion également de découvrir un
nouveau service la scaic business map
c'est toutes les ressources de saint
quentin en yvelines qui sont mises à
disposition des entreprises c'est pour
elles la possibilité de trouver un
fournisseur un partenaire un client dans
l'environnement local
les acteurs de l'immobilier avait rendez
vous le 20 octobre novotel de saint
quentin en yvelines
plus de 250 professionnels ont pu
découvrir les opportunités foncières et
immobilières sur notre territoire mais
aussi à versailles grand parc et paris
saclay
mardi 28 novembre le ski tube
accueillait les 7e rencontres
kreactive l'association regroupe une
centaine de femmes chefs d'entreprise
pour cette édition le sujet de l'argent
était abordée sous tous les angles pour
cette fin d'année 2010 est saint quentin
en yvelines étaient présents aussi mis
la 16e édition du salon de l'immobilier
d'entreprise avait lieu au palais des
congrès à paris il est indispensable
pour la couronne tout le monde qu'on
voit les nouveautés les innovations et
les nouvelles propositions comment on
peut être plus rentable être plus plus
rapide être plus simple requête de
beauregard on vient de le voir l'année
2017 a donc été plutôt bonne en terme
d'immobilier d'entreprise alors
j'imagine que du coup les voyants sont
au vert aussi pour pour 2018 tout à fait
alors en 2010 fait donc on a eu plus de
140 mille mètres carrés de mouvement et
de transactions en immobilier
d'entreprise
aussi bien pour la partie tertiaire les
bureaux et la partie aux activités
entrepôt ce qui est plus du double par
rapport à l'année 2016 avec des très
grandes signatures d'envergure avec le
conseil départemental soixante dix huit
avec assystem avec bmw
même chose pour pour l'activité de très
belles signatures avec la société n soul
qui est une filiale d'airbus
le groupe legendre qui continue de
s'étendre nature et découvertes qui re
signer un nouveau bail sur quinze mille
mètres carrés à trappes donc beaucoup de
beaucoup de très belles signatures
un segment qui fonctionne également très
bien c'est le segment inférieur à 1000
mètres carrés où on a eu plus de 60 de
transactions
dans le tertiaire et nous avons encore
des négociations en cours qui doivent
aboutir de milan début 2018
et là ça commence on va avoir une année
plutôt prometteuse également merci la
christine ce recueil de beauregard alors
juste en face de vaux ain failli bonjour
vous avez la directrice générale
adjointe en du développement économique
à saint quentin en yvelines
nous sommes en 2018 quels sont les
grands rendez-vous qui nous attendent
évidemment nous l'avons évoqué le grand
rendez-vous qui nous attend c'est
l'accueil de la ryder cup en septembre
2018 troisième événement médiatisé dans
le dans le monde les caméras du monde
entier auront les yeux braqués sur sur
saint quentin en yvelines c'est
évidemment pour nous un enjeu tout
particulier d'attractivité nous avons
déjà la chance sur saint quentin en
yvelines d'accueillir de nombreuses
filiales de groupes internationaux dans
les secteurs technologiques et on a bien
sûr à coeur de pouvoir promouvoir
l'offre d'accueil pour tous ces
investisseurs qui viendront à la fois
pour profiter de cet événement mais
c'est l'occasion aussi de nouer des
contacts business avec eux et de
promouvoir l'île de france et saint
quentin en yvelines
il ya d'autres rendez-vous alors la
ryder cup l'attractivité c'est un
rendez-vous qu'on retrouvera comme cette
année au mipim aussi mis donc c'est le
salon au mipim fin mars à cannes sur une
dimension internationale
le 6 me en fin d'année avec l'objectif
d'avoir une année 2010 8 sur les mêmes
auspices que celle de 2017 avec un
objectif pour nous dans le terme
d'attractivité qui est bien sûr de
bénéficier d' accompagner cette
dynamique des entreprises de notre
territoire mais aussi d'attirer de
nouvelles sociétés
l'attractivité de nouveaux comptes fait
partie de nos priorités sur sur 2018
merci anne failli
d'avoir été présente sur notre plateau
vais peut-être ajouter un dernier mot
oui parce que eux au delà de
l'attractivité
nous avons placé l'ensemble de notre
plan d'action 2018 sous le sous le signe
de la transformation numérique
notre président jean michel fau russe a
souhaité que le numérique compte tenu de
son potentiel en termes de développement
économique en termes de facteurs de
croissance en termes de création
d'emplois soit au coeur de notre action
tout au long de l'année 2018 comment ça
va se traduire de façon opérationnelle
nous avons mené très récemment une étude
qui a montré que plus de 5000 offres
d'emploi dans le secteur du numérique
ont été publiés par des entreprises
localisées sur saint quentin en yvelines
pendant ce premier semestre 2010 est on
voit bien qu'on a un enjeu tout
particulier de forme et d'offrir de
d'offrir des opportunités
professionnelles nouvelle aux habitants
de saint quentin en yvelines et donc de
répondre aussi aux besoins des
entreprises est ce qu'on s'en suivra sa
sueur sur tv 70 oui on aura l'occasion
de vous présenter ses 300 futurs
nouvelles places de formation que nous
avons mis en place à la casse nombre
d'organismes on viendra vous présenter
ça dès le mois de mars
merci al fayez merci à tous les prêts
d'avoir été présent sur ce plateau voilà
ce numéro touche à sa fin merci de
l'avoir suivi on se retrouve mardi 23
janvier pour un nouveau 7 8 et qu à très
bientôt
[Musique]